Citations, okay?
What are citations?
I know that wasn't the question, but let's talk about citations.
I know we're going basic, guys, but citations.
Citations have to do with your Google My Business.
The reason why we put that on the due diligence at the top is because citations are,
you guys remember when you set up your Google My Business
and it asks you for the name, the address, and the phone number.
It's called the NAP, N-A-P, right?
That is the core.
That is the basis.
That is the gospel.
That right there, that name, address, phone number,
what Google's doing in a citation is where else around the internet
is that name, address, phone number listed exactly like that?
Is it Yellow Pages? Is it Facebook?
Where, what places are those three things,
name, address, phone number, cited across the web, okay?
And the number of those typically does matter, okay?
The sheer volume of those.
So if you go look at citations, and one person has 5,000 citations,
which I've never seen, they typically have less than 50,
but let's say they have 500 citations,
that's going to be somebody that you need to look at that, okay?
But I want to clarify, citations have to do with the Google Maps,
have to do with ranking in the Google Maps section, not with the organic,
even though technically a high ranking in the Google Maps
will influence your organic ranking.
But when we're talking about citations,
and you look at the due diligence and it says citation,
we are referring to those things,
where is your name, address, phone number that shows on Google,
the exact one on Google, where else is it cited across the internet?
And how many places is it cited?
That's citations, whereas backlinks is how many other websites
are backlinked to you basically raising their hand and saying,
hey, I endorse this guy, and I'm popular, I'm so-and-so, I'm Forbes,
and I endorse lasvegastreeservice.com, right?
So that's the question there.